and that private yes episode not here
for your kiddies girls oh god all day
actually I'm not a customer [ __ ] I
should know what you want a freebie is
that us the families of the victims of
the origami killer asked me to
investigate the murders I came here just
to ask you some questions about there's
nothing you can do
my son's dead do you hear me he's dead I
mean remember this father the smallest
detail your call how the go home run my
name is purify I'm in parama welcome
back to Scott she'll be sleeping
simulator 2012 gonna sleep from this
angle and then I think am I going to I'm
going to wake up wait the baka Shelby
Shelby shoe we have a crime to solve
wake up alright kids I'd stay with it
just kind of relax a lot Shelby true
show me what are you doing
seriously oh I remember now I got my
badge [ __ ]
it's almost leet do you see that
all of us so close
well let's get up let's get our fat ass
up all right I needed the rest I haven't
been sleeping well since the murder
started up again all right well what do
you want
investigative soon the parents of all
the victims and all I've come up with is
this telephone and a box of origami
figures uh-huh
nice post shall be waah
who is that all right here we go
hello no it's a girl from the beginning
if I remembered anything you just want
my penis done can I come in sure sure
what I'm I have died that you can sit
down and so Lauren what's up didn't
really expect to see her wonder what she
wants
all right let's sit the suitor I just
remembered something Tommy maybe it's
not important but a letter arrived in
the mail the morning Johnny disappeared
I let him what kind of a letter probably
suggests Johnny's father that's that I
don't know what was incited but she read
it and then he left that the last time I
saw him and you think there's a
connection between that letter and
Johnny's death is that it
you remember anything else about the
letter
well I don't know why but I kept the
envelope yeah lemme look at that Allan
winter what about the stamp its and
trace it was mailed in the Carnaby
district the day before Johnny
disappeared well why do we got in the
back no sender well [ __ ] it this is
useless not particular thanks oh yeah
address the address it was typed with an
old typewriter ah could be a lead you
never know huh well thanks for help Lord
I'll let you know if it leads 10 wait I
I can't just sit around and do nothing
while you're out there looking for the
man who killed my son team up teen
mountains you came I've been thinking
and I I want to come with you help you
in your investigation mmm you can't do
anything that is that it's very
diplomatic nothing you can do to help
Lauren it's not a good idea
believe me ha ha ha if you won't let me
help you
I'm keeping the envelope it's all or
nothing girls but it's dangerous an
investigation like this you need body
fat like me and I don't have time to
play The Bodyguard
how many clues have you got mr. Shelby
like three or four envelope maybe your
only link to the killer
it's just the funny doesn't it it was a
stupid idea
sorry for wasting your time mr. Shea
okay wait wait wait
Jesus Christ well then when you're
really something special Lord huh
I'll give you that I'm just a mother
a mother who wants to find out who
killed her son now you want it oh no
your heart nurse you scare me
okay we're partners my partner yes all
right
I bet what we continue has these and
it's like that
well well well well well I have no idea
what we're gonna do oh oh oh why are we
going here maybe you better stay in the
car
partners remember wherever you go I go
uh okay
Hey ladies
I mean gentlemen what's up I got my
invite it's cool right
the girl doesn't have one but you don't
seem to care what are we doing here
partying to see Gordy Kramer I mean okay
Gordy Creek tycoon from Kramer
construction uh uh his son you think
maybe he's sir we gonna kill her but now
I just have a few questions that need
answers
hi okay nice dog
this seems like a fun party
I can I just have to blend in
Wow Kramer must be low yeah what is he
doing haha
whoa hell hey girl right mr. core
another time I can totally scar with
this one she doesn't no idea what she
doing I'm gonna say 40 Kramer you stay
here till I come back
it's places the bomb okay girl let me
know if you need me since I set up
parties come on there's a girl there do
something no I'm fine y'all suck out of
my way [ __ ] guys sleeping on a pool
table oh hello well I'm here might as
well have a drink that's the spirit
youngji babes and coke Gordy creamer
seems to be quite the party animal all
right where's the drink oh the girl Hey
look good-looking girl
keep your mind on the job Scotty yep
Scott it Susie a girl all right Raj you
come here often that never were a party
huh you cover up she's like oh god damn
it Scott I'm gonna make french god
damnit Scotty suck I'm so disappointed
idea alright let's find out what we're
doing [ __ ] is he doing are you dancing
or some [ __ ] okay uh the musical why
they have that goddamn music so loud all
right let me try this again let's try
this again
I would can't what is that guy doing uh
ha I quit party huh ha ha ha
yeah I'm dude well let's get better
acquainted pal yeah yeah that's the
space Shelby Shu my friend
huh okay job Josh Evans push now I got
me a new friend yeah that's a specialty
shoe
don't touch him like that that's
appropriate inappropriate all right so
can we talk to him and get clues out of
him hey watch it watch it what is it do
it that guy's crazy all right let's get
a drink
I love a scotch whiskey straight up no I
get drunk let's get drunk tonight faces
if us tonight y'all genitals genitals
alright what is this Gordie
have you seen Gordie sorry no I think I
know where it is actually so we might as
well
all right out of my way [ __ ] I think
it's over a year you got to go walk past
these guards excuse me I'm looking for
Gordy I saw him going upstairs a while
ago I'd be surprised if he comes down
again this evening
um well that's again I'm a detective I'm
a detective I'd like to speak to Gordie
Kramer Gordie hasn't seen anyone eat it
i buy them look here's mr. Franklin says
I should go up he talks so crazy if I
shut that one down your throat made it I
ate for sale all right if I want to see
Gordie Kramer I'm gonna have to go about
it some other way I guess I got a strep
[ __ ] I totally thought I had this one
all right why am I looking at this
so did you find Gordy he's upstairs we
got two goons blocking the way how the
hell are we doing this Lauren yes yes
hey what are you gonna do I'll come out
with a pair of high-heel leave it to me
just be ready to go as soon as they
leave the stairs
all right you go girl
you go wait Lord
hey girls
how are you do it hello Ida ha ha ha
nice going Laurie Lu tolling you go
learn
ah come on Laura and you party too hard
all right let me just sneak past these
mother
hahahahahahaha
Rex every time every time I tell you
Brad another one's gonna OD on the dance
floor another one I mean our pulse and
breathing wasn't completely fine I don't
understand it
alright he's got to be over here I mean
over here no I know where he is I might
as well not waste time we gotta get her
out of here
we gotta get it out and he's fapping to
cartoons
well yeah can I join in on the girls
well he look at the cartoons
now [ __ ] it then mr. Kramer Shh this is
the best part huh
I love that part my name is Scott Shelby
I'm a private detective I'm
investigating the case of the origami
killer I'd like to ask you a few
questions
how dare me what it's not that funny
okay it's very funny yeah salacious Tana
Davi it's the same thing over and over
again I'd like to know exactly what
happened to little Joseph brown Oh get
the hell out of here
hey don't treat that prostitutes like
that what do you want even liquor I'm
like a witness all little Joseph Brown
get into your limousine that was the
last time anybody ever saw him now I
know you've been arrested and
interrogated till your father made a
little phone call file was closed now
what I want to know is what really
happened why do you care you know just
so I make sure that you had nothing to
do with the origami killer do I make
myself clear kid was lost
I just offered to drive him home but
police arrived
I explained the misunderstanding and I
was released end of story
nothing to get excited about right no
let's be aggressive you don't think I'm
gonna fall for that [ __ ] do you Kramer I
know it's not the first time you tried
to lure a kid into your car I also know
you were more than a suspect for the
police the hell is now I am you head of
fire I think of something more credible
otherwise I'm gonna make sure you have
some serious problems all right spill
your [ __ ] bro
you like little boys wieners are very
well I'm the origami killer I get my
victims into my car skip the [ __ ] I
drowned them in rainwater and I dumped
them on a wasteland with an origami
figure in one hand and an orchid on the
chest I do that because
I'm Borg mr. Shelby and it's a creative
and entertaining way of having fun is
that good enough for you what do you
want more well I wanted to hear the
thing about that this interview is over
whoa get rid of this clown hey I'm not a
clown oh not today so I'll write in my
super all right I got a change screen
every time there's a QuickTime event
because I have delay when I play on the
other one but I kinda gotta be faster
[ __ ] haha
Rama that's how I roll
don't touch my nipples bro don't touch
my networks all he's fighting all of
them that's right Scott chablis
[ __ ]
Scott [ __ ] Gerald beard Scott
[ __ ] cherubic here's all the
suited people oh we get to counterpunch
oh he checks him row row got y'all Mitch
coach Allen movie cuz Shelby hit the
swim get 12 hits triangle get shot me
goes to the right shall be fights all
night get shake me shake is more control
gets all other police things with the
gun and Cairo big girl big girl me get
Shelby says you're negative [ __ ] so
dangerous game you're playing Kramer
nice going Scott you know who my father
is yes he only has to lift one finger
and you won't wake up tomorrow morning
you're the one that should be afraid mr.
Shelby I will lick your face Kramer I
will lick your face come on [ __ ]
gotcha Albert you're the man whisk a
channel beer
that [ __ ] team
he doesn't even give a [ __ ] about his
guards
well that was interesting
after all we're back we're crew I
present gonna dance episode ii i'm
videos if you enjoyed subscribe to
become a birthday and i'll see you next
episode over MMA everybody
you